vamos a las noticias de la economía con
Jorge Hurtado Jorge buenas noches para
usted Ángela Qué tal caluroso saludo
Jorge hace tiempo que no trabajábamos Sí
verdad vamos a comenzar con el llamado
del tesoro de Estados Unidos sobre la
fecha límite que ha dado para que el
gobierno de Estados Unidos llegue a un
acuerdo del techo de la deuda está
complicada la cosa bueno Esto mientras
crece la presión sobre los republicanos
para que lleguen a este acuerdo en los
próximos días la secretaría del tesoro
hoy y confirmó que es imposible que el
organismo pueda responder a los pagos
del gobierno estadounidense a principios
de junio lo que podría desencadenar en
el primer impago de la historia de
Estados Unidos este anuncio lo hace y el
enjuste un día antes de que el
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden
se reúne con el presidente de la cámara
de representantes Kevin karting Para
continuar con estas conversaciones que
iniciaron la semana pasada yelen ya ha
dicho en varias ocasiones que si el
congreso no lleva el límite de la deuda
Federal de 31.000 de 31,4 billones de
dólares podría desencadenar son ella una
crisis constitucional y lo que llama una
catástrofe económica y financiera para
su país que Por ende tendría
consecuencias también en el mundo algo
que nunca ha pasado y que Esperamos que
no llegue a pasar en otros temas Jorge
habló el ex director de silicon sobre la
quiebra de este banco de las empresas
tecnológicas qué fue lo que dijo esta
vez bueno dos cosas principalmente culpó
a la subida de los tipos de interés de
parte de la reserva Federal de ese país
y también a las redes sociales Greg
Baker el exilio de silicon recordó que
cuando la inflación en Estados Unidos
comenzaba a subir la Fed aseguraba que
era algo transitorio y que las tasas de
interés se mantendrían bajas El
Ejecutivo afirmó que la quiebra del
banco que dirigía y otros que siguieron
después fue influenciado por los rumores
en redes sociales que provocaron lo que
se conoce como una corrida bancaria
silicon trabajaba con startup
tecnológicas que perdieron mucho dinero
tras la pandemia y también mucho de su
capital estaba invertido en a largo
plazo que perdieron valor precisamente
con esta subida de los tipos de interés
la quiebra de este banco arrastró a
otros bancos como el sidneter Bank y el
First Republic Bank bueno Y ustedes qué
opina porque este es un tema de no
terminar no bueno sin duda alguna las
tasas de interés influenciaron bastante
pero hubo malas decisiones que se
tomaron en su momento y que por supuesto
Siempre se busca un enemigo externo no a
la situación y que también han quedado
en evidencia Jorge vamos a seguir
hablando de quiebras porque el grupo de
medios país media Se declaró en
bancarrota qué noticia tan dura bueno la
compañía consiguió un acuerdo con sus
acreedores para venderla la compañía de
medios que llegó a alcanzar
5.700 millones de dólares en valor de
Mercado lleva meses batallando con las
finanzas debido a la falta de
anunciantes la empresa nación Montreal
hace 30 años y se posicionó entre la
audiencia joven con sus cortos
documentales que no también un premio
pulsar en el 2020 y varios premios emmys
la empresa dijo que seguirá operando y
que completará este proceso de venta en
los próximos dos o tres meses su quiebra
sin duda marca un precedente para los
medios digitales pero no es el único
antes ya este año boostfit cerró sus
operaciones de noticias y otro medio
insider recordará el 10% de su planilla
noticia lamentable la de la crisis en
los medios de comunicación ahora ahí
también más temas sobre tecnologías el
multimillonario y los anuncia
inversiones en Francia bueno anunció
específicamente a través de una de sus
empresas que es tesla mosc participó de
un encuentro de responsables de
multinacionales organizados por el
presidente francés Emmanuel macrón ahí
el presidente francés anunció
inversiones de 13 mil millones de euros
que crearán según él unos ocho mil
empleos en los próximos meses en el
evento participaron los consejeros
delegados de empresas como la
farmacéutica pfizer también la
siderúrgica arcelo vital la química
solday o el grupo de entretenimiento
Walt Disney elon musk No precisó si esa
inversión de mencionó en Francia sería
una gran giga factura de chica factoría
de baterías o también una planta de
ensamblaje de vehículos la reunión se
celebró en el Palacio de Versalles y
macron aún es blanco de protestas tras
firmar el mes pasado su controversial
reforma de pensiones que eleva la edad
de jubilación en ese país claro y aquí
vemos los esfuerzos para tratar de
contrarrestar esa gran oposición Ya
vamos llegando al final Jorge y es que
Amazon va a introducir un sistema de
búsqueda de productos pero al estilo del
chat gpt muy llamativo Esto sí es
interesante bueno de esta forma del
gigante del ecommerce entra en línea con
esfuerzos como el de Google y también
Microsoft que está en una batalla por la
Inteligencia artificial según fuentes de
bloomberg la empresa está reimaginando
Amazon Search con una experiencia
conversacional interactiva diseñada para
ayudar a los usuarios a encontrar
respuestas a preguntas comparar
productos y recibir sugerencias
personalizadas antes de comprar la barra
de búsqueda de la parte superior de esta
aplicación y también de la página de
inicio de Amazon son la portada de
millones de compradores que buscan un
producto en concreto y la experiencia de
búsqueda de Amazon ha sido criticada por
el aumento de anuncios de los resultados
y otros contenidos patrocinados sin duda
cuando uno se mete a buscar siempre
aparece algo de publicidad Pues yo no he
hecho el ejercicio pero ya con esta
noticia podría hacerlo Muchas gracias a
usted Jorge De nada nos vemos en la
próxima Claro que sí es hora de ir con
el debate
[Música]